[संगीत]
कैसे हो
तो पैसा डाउनलोड पर जान के बाद में जो
अपना आप अपने डिवाइस के साथ रिलीज हुई थी
उसे कर लेना यहां पर डाउनलोड हो जा के चेक
कर सकते हो
इसके हिसाब से डाउनलोड कर लगा नहीं तो आप
खुद के यहां पर सिलेक्ट करके भी डाउनलोड
कर सकते हो डाउनलोड वाले बटन पर क्लिक
करेंगे और ये अपना डाउनलोड चालू हो जाएगा
आधे में नेट की स्पीड अच्छा है तो यहां पर
क्लिक करूंगा और यहां पे रन पे क्लिक
करूंगा रन पे क्लिक करने के बाद में मेरे
सामने आया है अभी मॉडिफाइड सेटअप का ऑप्शन
सो बट ये आप लोग अगर फर्स्ट टाइम कर रहे
हो तो मोस्ट अभी नहीं आएगा ये आप लोगों के
सामने
सेटअप आएगा वहां पे जाके आपको कस्टमर
क्षेत्र की जगह पे वहां पर रहेगा वो वाले
सॉल्यूशन पे क्लिक कर देना सर चीज अब अपने
आप कर देगा अपन लोग को जो करने की जरूर
नहीं है नीचे एक ऑप्शन है आपका एड तू पाठ
का उसे पे टिक कर देना ताकि वो अपने पास
में चला जाएगा जहां भी अपन चाहे वहां पर
इंस्टॉल जो अपने लाइब्रेरी है वो इंस्टॉल
कर सकेंगे
स्वप्न वहां पर कम इजीली हो जाएगा तो ये
अपना थोड़ा सा इंसुलेशन का फास्ट रीकैप
हालांकि मैं कल भी पूरे सिस्टम में फास्ट
ही था आज करूंगा थोड़ा अच्छे से जाए अपना
सेशन सो आज फिर अपन अब चालू करते हैं अपना
जैसे अपना इंसुलेशन हो जाएगा तो यहां पर
आइडली लिखना आइडियल लिखने के बाद में इंटर
मारना तो ये सामने अपना शैली खुलना है
मैंने कल बताया था ये चीज अभी रिवर्स करता
हूं और शैली राहत है अपना आ जैसे वो इसके
अंदर भी सेल्स होते हैं अब लिरिक्स के
अंदर बेस्ट सेल होता है तो ये पाइथन का भी
अपना शैली है तो आज अपन चालू करते हैं
न्यू फाइल और न्यू फाइल में जाएंगे अपन
पहले इसको से कर लेते हैं तो यहां पर से
करते हैं से कर लेट हूं दे तू
डॉट पी ए करके मैं से कर देता हूं
ए जाए
अपने प्रिंट हेलो वर्ल्ड लिखने हैं
तो यहां पे देखो
तो मैं इस या तो उसको मैं हटा डन लाइन को
नहीं तो मैं उसको कमेंट कर दो की बाद में
पर फ्यूचर उसे अगर मैं इसको उसे करना
चाहूं तो कैसे रहेगा
ओके सो हां
सो ये मैंने कमेंट कर दूंगा तो बाद में
इसको रीड नहीं करेगा कमेंट क्या करता
कमेंट करने से क्या राहत है की अपना
कंप्लीशन इसको अगर रीड नहीं करता है जो
इसका इंटरप्रेटर राहत है वहां के रीड नहीं
करता है इसको अपने लिए छोड़ देते हैं की
हां अभी चलो दान किया तो एक लाइन अपनी
जिंदगी और ये जो इसके अंदर जो ये ए है ये
ए होता है अपने वेरिएबल ये हो तो अपना
वैल्यू वेरिएबल को वैल्यू साइन होती है और
वेरिएबल के अंदर एक चीज और ध्यान रखना की
वेरिएबल जो राहत है प्लस स्पेशल कैरक्टर्स
के नाम पर बस एक अंडरस्कोर भी अपनी उसे कर
सकते हैं उसके अलावा और कोई स्पेशल
कैरक्टर्स इसके अंदर इस्तेमाल नहीं कर
सकते हैं स्टार्टिंग में नंबर नहीं होना
चाहिए अपना सिर्फ वेरिएबल मतलब अल्फाबेट
से ही अपनी स्टार्टिंग हनी चाहिए
तो आपके साथ वेरिएबल भी समझ गए होंगे
तो अपने टाइप फंक्शन का इस्तेमाल करते हैं
अपने खुद के भी मनाएंगे उसकी टेंशन
बिल्कुल नहीं करने का अपने यहां सब कुछ है
इंतजार है ये एक अपने पता लगा लिया है ये
एक इंटीरियर है तो किसी के
विजुअल कोड में कोडिंग करेंगे तो बटर
रहेगा
क्योंकि बिगनर्स के लिए अपन बात कर रहे
हैं अभी इसके अंदर फिंगर को कुछ फूड की जो
लाइन होती है अगर कुछ कोड के तो कीवर्ड
होते हैं वो थोड़ा सा दिमाग में रहना
चाहिए की कौन सा कौन सा क्या होता है वे
एस कोड क्या होता है ना एकदम एडवांस वालों
के लिए राहत है की यार तुमको इतना कीवर्ड
याद नहीं रहेगी इतने मेरी बस हमने बनाए
रहेंगे कौन सा क्या वेरिएबल क्या कहां
लगाने का वो सब वो सब चीजों के लिए अपन
उसे करते हैं वहां पर उसे कैसे के अंदर बट
अभी अपन थोड़ा सीखे रहे तो कुछ चीज अपन को
याद रखना ही पड़ेगी नहीं तो फिर अगर आपने
पहले अगर एडवांस वाली चीज पर जाकर कम
करेंगे तो वो अपन को बेसिक क्लियर नहीं
करवा पाएगा अपना अगर कल को अभी अपन में
आइडिया नहीं चालू कर रहा हूं ना तो मुझे
कल को कोई भी आस या कुछ भी कुछ भी लाकर दे
दो नोटपैड में भी जाके लिख लूंगा मैं बट
अगर मैं बीएसपी चालू करते रहूंगा तो मुझे
बाद में नोटपैड में कोचिंग करने को दिक्कत
आएगी जहां पर वे एस कोड वगैरा रहेंगे ही
नहीं तो वहां मेरी बहुत ज्यादा दिक्कत ए
जाएगी इस चक्कर के अंदर अपन यहां पर इसको
इस्तेमाल करते हैं
तो मां लो की हां अभी ये ना एक का टाइप
जैसे मैंने बताया की अभी इंटीरियर था या
पीछे देखते हैं ये देखो ये इंटीरियर है तो
मैंने इसका इंटीरियर टाइप पता कर लिया है
अब मैं चाहता हूं की यार ये तो देखो ये तो
इंतजार हो गया बट मैं चाहता हूं की यार ये
स्ट्रिंग के स्ट्रिंग बना देता है उसको
मैं तो मैं स्ट्रिंग बनाने के लिए यहां पे
डबल को लगा सकता हूं बट
यहां पर
लिख देंगे
ऐसे बढ़िया तरीके से खेल सकते हैं
आई थिंक सबको समझ में ए गया रहेगा एक चीज
के बड़े में इस चीज को अपन बोलते हैं टाइप
कास्टिंग किसी एक टाइप को दूसरी टाइप में
बादल देने को कास्ट कर देने को कष्ट
सिस्टम मुझे बहुत बेकार लगता है वैसे
इंडिया का भी बट ठीक है यहां पाइथन में भी
क्वेश्चन सिस्टम चला है अपना जिसको अपन
टाइप कास्टिंग बोलते हैं सो यही है टाइप
कास्टिंग का चीज अपना और डिफरेंट तरीके के
रेट टाइप्स वगैरा भी होते हैं जिसमें मुझे
कुछ रिलेटिव्स के बड़े में अपन आज बात
करने वाले हैं मेरे को फिर भी डिटेल बता
देता हूं कौन-कौन से लेते हैं ये ऐसा नहीं
है की साड़ी डेटाबेस यही है और भी डाटा
सोते हैं आप पता करेंगे पता लगेंगे अपन कम
इसलिए अभी पढ़ रहे हैं क्योंकि यही अपने
बेसिकली कम आते हैं
ये लिस्ट है ना ये लिस्ट बहुत ज्यादा कम
आने वाला है
लिस्ट इतना उसे नहीं दिखेगा इन अप कितने
में कोर्स करके जाके देखोगे ये सेटअप को
दिखेगा ही नहीं
है
वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर करते हैं
चीजों के बड़े में इन चीजों का अपन खेलने
बढ़िया तरीके से ये ये राहत है अपने
डिक्शनरी राहत है
तो यहां पर
यह अपना यह डिक्शनरी
इस चीज में ध्यान रखना पाइथन जो होता है
अपना कैसे सेंसेटिव सा लैंग्वेज है ये
अपना ठीक है इसके अंदर साड़ी चीज आपको
स्मॉल लेटर्स में देखेंगे तो आपको ऐसे का
भी लगेगा नहीं की यार ये कैसे सरिता में
कोई चीज है क्या पाइथन के अंदर लेकिन अगर
आप दीप इनसाइड देखोगे पीठा प्रिंट मैं अगर
पिक कैपिटल कर दूंगा तो वो कम नहीं करेगा
वापस क्योंकि ये चीज जो है ये एकदम कैसे
सेंसेटिव है स्मॉल लेटर में लिखा गया है
ये बहुत अच्छी बात है अगर अपन उसके अंदर
जाते हैं क्या कहते हैं अपना जावा में
जाते हैं तो जावा में system.out सिस्टम
का एस्केपिटल करो फिर वो चीज बहुत दिमाग
खराब कर देती है ये चीज अच्छी जाए तो
स्ट्रिंग क्या है कैपिटल करो तो वो चीज
बहुत खराब से लगती है मुझे भी तो अगर अपन
अपने चेक करो तो जोड़ो में टाइप्स बोले वो
क्या सच में है की नहीं है मैं सही हूं की
नहीं जरा हम चेक करते हैं इसके अंदर यहां
पे ये डालूंगा और इस चीज को फास्ट करने के
लिए थोड़ा कॉपी पेस्ट का इस्तेमाल करेंगे
कोई भी स्ट्रिंग इस बेस्ट गैस तुम भी करो
मजा आएगा मतलब ये नहीं की किसी दूसरे को
कल उठा के दाल लो खुद का लॉजिक लगाने का
दूसरे कोड भी कॉपी होते हैं चाट गुप्त में
इस्तेमाल करूंगा करता हूं
सबको अपना कम आसन चाहिए कोई दूसरा कम करके
अच्छी तरीके से यहां पे लगा देता हूं
तो पहले मैंने बताया की अपना लिस्ट था फिर
मैंने बताया की सेट है फिर मैं रतापल्ली
बताया था यह भी बताया था ये स्ट्रिंग भी
बताया था ये इंतजार भी बताया था ये अपलोड
भी बताया था ये बुलियन मैंने आज
देख लेते हैं अपना 10 मिनट होने वाले हैं
सो एक क्विकली अपन देख लेते हैं की कैसे
एक अपन इनपुट लेते हैं
यह रिवीजन नहीं है यह
और वैल्यू
करूंगा
की इस ए का टाइप क्या होगा मैंने कल बताया
था
गैस जल्दी बताना
है की इस 10 का टाइप क्या होगा
अच्छा लगा प्रिंस
चलो बढ़िया बात है
यहां पर मैं ईट करके लिखूंगा
चलो कोई बात नहीं बट फिर भी अपन ए जाते
हैं अपने लिस्ट की तरफ केवल लिस्ट किस
चिड़िया का नाम है
सब्जी लेकर आने के लिए
ऐसे ही रहेगा
से करते हैं लिस्ट में जाकर से करने के
लिए अपने बस बहुत साड़ी डाटा बेसिस भी
होते हैं लेकिन छोटी-मोटी चीज अगर अपन को
से करनी है इन प्रोग्राम ही तो अपन उसे
चीज का लिस्ट ओपन अगले लेक्चर में पढ़ेंगे
आराम से बस अभी सब कुछ ऊपर से ना जाए
तो सब कुछ ऊपर से ना जाए इसके लिए मैं बता
रहा हूं की
डिक्शनरी क्या होता है
हेलो हेलो
बाकी पूरा टाइम बाय गॉड को नेटवर्क नहीं
होता है
तो फिर से चलते हैं लिस्ट क्या होती है
फिर से मैं बता देता हूं
की लिस्ट और तप वगैरा के अंदर अपनी कुछ
सिंपल सी चीज एक ही वेरिएबल में अपन को
ज्यादा चाहिए स्टोर करनी है तो उनके लिए
अपन लिस्ट और तप का इस्तेमाल करते हैं
अपने देखा की पहले अपन ए बना रहे थे फिर
उसके अंदर एक ही चीज लिख लेते हैं फिर बी
के अंदर एक और चीज लिख रहे हैं पीसी के
अंदर एक और चीज लिख रहे हैं बहुत झंझट
वाला सीन था
तो उसकी उसके लिए अभी अपन क्या करेंगे की
एक ही वेरिएबल के अंदर अपन मल्टीपल चीज
डालेंगे अब ये जरूरी नहीं है की इसके अंदर
अपन को मतलब से में डाटा टाइप की चीज मां
लो की स्ट्रिंग स्ट्रिंग भी दाल रहे हैं
या फिर नंबर नंबर ही दाल रहे हैं तो वैसे
सीन नहीं रहने वाला है गैस इसके अंदर मस्त
अपना अपन अलग-अलग डाटा टाइप्स की चीज एक
साथ दाल सकते हैं लिस्ट और टप्पर्स में
दोनों के अंदर से चीज राहत है ठीक है
टप्पल्स के अंदर बस कुछ चीज अलग सी रहती
है वो चीज अपन आगे देखते हैं क्या राहत है
तो सबसे पहले मैं समझना है मीत टेबल
इनविटेबल चीज क्या होती है
जो जिन चीज को अपन मॉडिफाई कर सके म होता
है जो चीज अपन मॉडिफाई नहीं कर सकते
ठीक है सो लिस्ट जो होती है वह टेबल राहत
है मतलब इनको अपन मॉडिफाई कर सकते हैं और
तप आईएमएमयूटेबल राहत है जिसका मतलब है की
अपन इनको मॉडिफाई नहीं कर सकते हैं बट
अपुन डेफ्रॉनिक से बाढ़ रहे हैं गैस सो
बाय हार्दिक आशीर्वाद
सिक्योरिटी तो अपन इसमें भी तप में भी
चेंज करेंगे उसकी अपने पास पड़े हैं सो
डोंट वारी गैस
स्टेक्स मेरे डिफरेंस राहत है आप मेरे साथ
पहले के कल के लेक्चर में या फिर अभी भी
देखा होगा एक चीज के लिए की एक स्कर्ट ग
रहे थे एक जगह पेरेंट्स ग रहे थे एक जगह
खाली पैकेट वगैरा ग रहे थे तो कैलीग्राफी
सीन अपन बाद में देखेंगे पहले मैं
स्क्वायर फिट्स और पेरेंट्स नमस्ते
रहते हैं जिनका मुंह टेढ़ा होता है वो
वाले
ठीक है
तो ये एक में डिफरेंस
राहत है क्योंकि लिस्ट अपना पड़ता है चेंज
कर पाते हैं
थोड़ा मुश्किल से चेंज हो जाति है
सीधे में चेंज नहीं कर सकते हो फास्टली
बताया जाता है मतलब इतना फर्क है पता ही
नहीं पड़ेगा
ठीक है एन डायनेमिक चीजों के लिस्ट कम
आएगी और बातें भाई क्योंकि जीनियस कर सकते
हैं तो डायनेमिक जगह ही कम आने का है और
टपल्स आईएमएमयूटेबल रहते हैं तो कोई
ज्यादा जीनियस हो नहीं पाएंगे क्योंकि मैं
डबल्स का भी उसे नहीं किया जाता है की
लिस्ट है भैया चीज चेंज ही नहीं करनी
पड़ेगी तो लिस्ट में भी चीज चेंज नहीं
करेंगे तो बस कहे को बनाए एक और नया
वेरिएबल लगाओ फिर एक और अपना प्रोसेसिंग
बढ़ेगा मतलब नहीं वो चीज का ठीक है ना तो
लिस्ट ये अपने सवाल करते हैं आगे जाके
लिस्ट में मजा आएगा तुम लोग भी अगर
प्रोग्राम में अगर करोगे या जो लोग
तुम्हारे में से प्रोग्राम में करते हैं
वो लोग लिस्ट कहीं मैंने इस्तेमाल करते
होंगे मोस्ट वेलकम मुझे लगता है सो अब आगे
आते हैं इसके अंदर कुछ चल मैथर्ड होते हैं
और लिस्ट टॉपर्स में तो चंद ही होते हैं
ठीक है तो लिस्ट के अंदर मैथर्ड अपन देखते
हैं तो उसमें राहत है अपना की अपेंड राहत
है
ठीक है और तप के अंदर काउंट इंडेक्स ये दो
प्रकार के ही हैं
तो लिस्ट वाले अपना भी आगे देखेंगे
हालांकि
डेट अलसो
एक डेड घंटा चलेगा
ट्रेडिंग राहत है मतलब इसका मतलब यह की
मतलब दोनों ही ट्रैवल चीज हैं लिस्ट और
ट्यूबलेस ये ट्रैवल चीज मतलब ऐसा ही किया
अपन वन बाय वन इन चीजों को एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं जिन लोगों को यहां पे लूप्सोफस के
बड़े में पता होगा तो उन लूप्स के अंदर
अपन कोई उसे कर सकते हैं
और डिक्शनरी इसको भी वे अराउंड है जो अपन
उसे कर सकते हैं बाकी ऐसे डिक्शनरी उसे
नहीं की जा शक्ति है वो अब मां आगे
देखेंगे कल देखेंगे वो चीज बट हां मतलब
तुम्हारे दिमाग में आशंका नहीं देनी चाहिए
और शंका समाधान अपन करेंगे यहां पर
जो भी क्वेश्चंस वगैरा यहां पर सीधा चाट
बॉक्स में दाल देना मैं चाट बॉक्स में खोल
के बैठा हूं तो डोंट वारी
लिस्ट को लेकर
बेसिकली लिस्ट बनाते कैसे हैं
अपना लिस्ट हो गया
बेसिकली बनाते हैं मतलब बहुत ज्यादा उसे
होती है क्योंकि अपन को बाद में डाटा
डालना देते हैं तो उसके लिए एंप्लाइज बनाई
जाति है
शायद मैंने गलत तरीके से एक्सप्लेन किया
हुआ था मैं इसकी बात कर रहा हूं जो अपने
एलएस के अंदर है
मोहित भाई कुछ ज्यादा ही आता है लगता है
वेरिएबल नाइस नाइस
गोपाल भाई मेरे दिल की बात समझ का रहे हैं
लव यू गोपाल भाई
ठीक है
अगर मैं डबल डबल भी लगाऊंगा ना यहां पर
डबल लगा दूंगा तू भी यहां आना है क्योंकि
घंटा इसको फर्क नहीं पड़ता
यहां पर लिखेंगे
एक किसी चीज निकालना को तो यहां पर
1234 नाइस
क्या है
तो उसके लिए अपन लेंथ का इस्तेमाल
डालोगे किसी भी चीज खराब हो गया लेने
निकाल लगा उसका
इस्तेमाल राहत है
यहां पर अपन देख पाएंगे की डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट टाइप्स चाहिए स्ट्रिंग है यह अपना
इंतजार है बुलियन है प्लॉट है एकदम नाइसली
ठीक है
माउस इस्तेमाल करता हूं
पोजीशन पर खड़ा है
यह किस प्रकार
तो इंडेक्स चालू होती है हमेशा अपने जीरो
जीरो से चलती है और माइंस
वन का मतलब है अपना लेंथ रहती है लेंथ चला
है ये अपना क्योंकि चालू अपना जीरो से हो
रही है
लेंथ अपना निकालना है यहां पे वन तू थ्री
करके ये निकाल रहा है पर तक तो अगर अपन
लॉजिकल भी देखें तो अगर जीरो चालू करेंगे
तो एन - 1 तक ही जाएगा तो ये बेसिकली ऐसा
था बट अब अपन किसी चीज का अगर इंडेक्स पता
लगे की किस चीज का क्या इंडेक्स है तो वो
पता ऐसे लगाया जाएगा मैं एक कम करता हूं
नीचे वाले को थोड़ा सा और नीचे ले जाता
हूं
गैस मैं कॉपी पेन में भी बहुत घटिया तरीके
से लिखना हूं अगर मैंने किसी को मेरी
राइटिंग है तो आप लोग को लेकर कहां
प्रोग्राम में डॉक्टर होना चाहिए था मेरे
घरवाले
जीरो ठीक है
तो यहां पर ए जाएगा
ठीक है
जीरो में नेगेटिव में नहीं होता है
अब मैंने पढ़ा तो दिया है अभी यह बात सत्य
है की नहीं
अब इसका प्रूफ करेंगे अपने प्रिंट कमांड
एक्सप्रेशन क्या होगा
जी तरीके से मैंने बताया की नहीं यह
वाटापन आगे देखेंगे बट अभी मुझे बताओ की
जी तरीके से मैंने बताया तुम लोग के समझ
में ए रही है बैंड करके पोजीशन क्या होगा
मुझे एक बार नेगेटिव और पॉजिटिव दोनों
इंडेक्स चाट में लिखकर भेज दो फटाफट
नेगेटिव माइनस बढ़िया है
की नहीं
आया ठीक है
अपना
यह माइंस वन माइंस तू माइंस थ्री
कर सकते हैं किसी भी इसका लिस्ट का वैल्यू
को ऐसे एक्सेस किया जाता है अपन यहां पर
लिस्ट का वेरिएबल डालते हैं फिर ऐसा नहीं
है की लिस्ट चेक करने में यहां पर अपन ऐसे
ये स्क्वायर पैकेट लगा रहे हैं यह हर जगह
लगेगा
मुझे वन से लेकर 20 तक जानते हैं वह शांत
रहना ठीक है
यह तो तीन ही वैल्यू आया अभी तक आया ही
नहीं तो होता क्या है
जो अपना और वाला जो यह इंडेक्स राहत है
इसका और वाले से एक कम पर रुक जाता है
वहां से एक आगे का देना पड़ेगा ताकि वहां
पर
एक आगे तक दे रहे हैं तो आगे से एक कम में
चलेगा तो ज्यादा अपन को चाहिए वहां तक ए
जाएगा ठीक है गैस
ठीक है
और वाले तो क्यों नहीं चला भाई यह तो पैसे
बनाने वालों को ही पता होगा
नहीं होगा मेरे पास भी जो है वह वैसा ही
रहेगा
होमवर्क रहेगा मुझे याद दिलाना कोई भी और
में की मैंने दिया है नेगेटिव का ट्राई
करने को
मैं लिख लेट हूं एक जगह पर
इसको
काटा जाता है जैसे स्लाइस निकलते हैं तो
अगर अपन को चाहिए
कुछ भी आता रहना अपना प्रिंट होना चाहिए
अपन को रुकने का नहीं है प्रिंट हो जान का
तो मैं ना और का कुछ दूंगा ही नहीं है ना
कॉलर लगा के यहां छोड़ दूंगा
ठीक है ना
तू ही देखो
ठीक है अब हम चाहते हैं की भाई अपना यह
चले सेटिंग का सर है लेकर एक दो तीन कर तक
आया अपना
तो
जीरो वन तू कर से कम चला
तो ऐसे
तो स्टार्टिंग का सर ए गया
तो देखो यह जो भी लिखा हुआ था
उसकी जगह
तो उसे कैसे में मैं करूंगा ना
मैं अगर
डॉट इन शर्ट
वाले पर था वहां पर तू ए गया
ठीक है बताओ
जल्दी
चलो फिर से रिपीट कर देते हैं
ओके रिपीट
रिपीट ओके देखो
इंसर्ट कमांड से क्या हुआ ना की अपने आगे
बढ़ाने
कर दिया ठीक है
तो क्या था आउटपुट
तुम खुद ही गैस करो
समझा जा शक्ति है
अब आप आगे जाके बहुत सारे ऐसे मतलब मोड
आएगी जी मोड पे आपको क्या रहेगा ना आपको
सामने वही बांदा बोले है क्या मुझे ना ऐसा
वगैरा नहीं चाहिए
ठीक है ऐसे प्रोग्राम चाहिए कुछ चाहिए तो
उसमें क्या रहेगा ना आपको आपको उसे
प्रोग्राम का आउटपुट देख किया समझना
पड़ेगा की मतलब की इसको खुद कर कैसे बनाया
जाता है आपको बाकी लैंग्वेज कहानी भी मतलब
बाकी लैंग्वेज में भी कोड लिखे हुए
दिखेंगे इसको हमको पाइथन में कन्वर्ट करना
पड़ेगा तो वो चीज आपको उसका आउटपुट देख के
या कोड देख के समझ में आना चाहिए की अरे
चीज चल कैसे रही है ये दाल दो ऐसा ए रहा
है वो डालो तो वैसा ए रहा है ये चीज यहां
पर ए जाता है
समझ में आएगी
सॉल्यूशन नहीं कर सकते हैं यहां पर तो
टेलीग्राम चैनल
पे आना वहां पर आने के बाद मैं आराम से
अपना
स्क्रीनशॉट डालना और उसके बाद वहां पे
आपको रिप्लाई मिल जाएगा डोंट वारी
खुश हो जाएगा तो मैं ही वहां पे क्या बता
दूंगा जैसा भी सीन रहेगा बस आ जो भी आपके
ज्यादा अगर प्रॉब्लम्स वगैरा हैं तो आप
वहां पर जाना वहां पर जा के लिख देना फिर
प्रॉब्लम मुझे टैक्स मुझे टैग कर देना
वापस दी अंडरस्कोर ch3f अंडरस्कोर ऑफिशल
ये मेरा रहेगा मतलब वहां सीटू करके दिखे
जाएगा आपको अगर आप एडमिन को अटैक करेंगे
तो
सही अपना इंसर्ट कमांड और इन दोनों
डिफरेंस है अब मां लो की अपन को है ना कोई
चीज चाहिए ना और में अपने एड कर दे ये मैं
तू चाहता हूं बीच में नहीं आया यार भाई
साहब यह बात करोगे यहां से दिक्कत उन
लोगों ने क्या अरे कम करो आप जब पीछे जाकर
खड़े हो जो
पीछे भेज देते हैं उनको ये चीज ऐसा नहीं
है इसके अंदर बट हां कम आएगा
अब देखो ये तू चला के पीछे ठीक है
तुम मेरे बीच में भी बताओ तुम जो आखिर में
तो अब वह आखिरी में चला गया तू ये अपेंड
कमांड ने क्या किया उसको आखिरी में भेज
दिया
उसमें उसे जगह पर वैल्यू ए रहा था उसके
बाद में
जब अपन ने इंसर्ट कमान का उसे किया तो उसे
पोजीशन पर वैल्यू जा रहा था और बाकी के
पीछे जा रहे थे उसके
अपेंड नहीं क्या किया अपेंड ने जो वैल्यू
है उसे वैल्यू को ही यहां पे जो आएगा ना
ये वैल्यू है ये अपना लिस्ट है
यह मेथड है
ए नहीं कोई वेरिएबल के अंदर ए प्लस बी कर
देता हूं
और इसने
लगा दिया
कैसे करते हैं
[संगीत]
एमएससी
मुझे
फिर उसके बाद
एक दिन जरूर आएगा
अगर अपन को
क्या करना पड़ेगा यहां पर
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन लिख दो जीरो एक उड़ने का
है मेरे को तो मैंने देखा है ये देखो ये
ना परफेक्ट खासियत क्या है ना
इस पॉप कमांडर क्या उदा दिया जो नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन पे था या नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन देखिए
यहां पर ये उदा दिया है ठीक है ना अब इसे
खासियत क्या है ना अभी दिखाई हैं
यहां पर
थोड़ा हुआ
ठीक है
तो यह ऐसा रहेगा ठीक है
ओके
और भी फंक्शंस के अंदर होता है
वह मैं बता दूंगा और
ठीक है
की नहीं वो कैसे पता लगाएंगे अपन
है
इसका मतलब यह हुआ
देखते रहेंगे
आगे आने वाले
होते रहेगा अपना उसके बड़े में सो ये देखो
ये वन इन ए का मतलब क्या हुआ ना की ये वन
ए के अंदर है क्या ये पता लगाया उसने की
वन ए के अंदर है की नहीं तो है तो इसने
दिखा दिया ट्रू ठीक है ना
चेक भाई ए तू ए के अंदर है की नहीं
अब एक्स के ध्यान रखना मैंने एक स्ट्रिंग
में लिखा है यहां पर ठीक है ना मैंने ए
नॉर्मली नहीं लिख दिया क्योंकि अगर मैं एक
और नॉर्मली लिख दूंगा तो एक वेरिएबल हो
जाएगा अपन को इसको वेरिएबल नहीं है ये एक
अपने स्ट्रिंग है अपन को स्ट्रिंग वे में
लिखना है लोग क्या करते है ना यहां पर
नॉर्मली ये लिख देंगे फिर वो वेरिएबल हो
जाता है
तो अपन को वेरिएबल वाला सीन नहीं करने का
है अपन को स्ट्रिंग देखने का ये स्ट्रिंग
इसके अंदर है की नहीं
फल क्योंकि अपन ने उदा दिया था ऊपर वाले
में तो है
ठीक है
इस वाले में है
इस वाले में नहीं रहा ठीक है
अगर समझ में
तो ऐसा ही चीज क करती है
तो आगे चल के पास सब देखेंगे
और बाकी के दिन भी आप लोग आओ बढ़िया तरीके
से तो हां तो ये अपना यहां अपना खत्म होता
है अपना लिस्ट यहां पर खत्म होता है अपना
ठीक है
सब अपना आगे बढ़ते हैं अपने टप्पल की तरह
जिनकी मेरी तरह स्पेलिंग खराब है
तो मैं प्रेजेंटेशन
हां जो लोग है की वह प्रैक्टिकल के टूल्स
बनेंगे क्या हैकिंग प्रैक्टिकल जरूर बनेगा
अभी अपन देखते हैं की आप लोग कितना समझ
रहे हो कित क्या है उसे रिकॉर्डिंग अपन
देखेंगे कौन से टूल बनाए जाएंगे आप चाहे
तो अपना सेशन दे सकते हो अपना डेफ्रॉनिक्स
के जो टेलीग्राम चैनल है वहां पर आओ अपने
सजेशन दो अच्छा लगेगा आगे उसे पर कम किया
जाएगा बात कर ही जाएगी अगर आपको ऐसा लगता
है आपको कुछ कस्टम टूल्स वगैरा भी बनवाने
के हैं की आपको अपने हिसाब से टूल बनवाने
हैं तो आप वो भी बता सकते हो एक आइडिया के
लिए की ऐसे टीएस भी बन सकते हैं या बना
सकते हैं तो वो भी हम पूरा एक्सेप्ट करते
हैं ठीक है हमारा नेक्स्ट टूल भी है उसके
ऊपर ही अगर आप चाहते हो की कुछ और अगर हो
तो आप वो भी बताओ वो सेशन हमारा पूरा
एक्सेप्टेबल है यहां पर किसी भी इसके लिए
आपको नया टूल्स बनवाने है तो वो भी हम
बनाते हैं बनाते हैं आप चाहते हो की आपको
आपसे बनवाएं तो वो भी होगा तो डोंट वारी
टेलीग्राम चैनल पर जो वहां पे पूरा भर दो
उसको इस टाइम कर दो वहां पे जाकर के यह
चाहिए वो चाहिए ऐसा चाहिए वैसे चाहिए तो
कोई कोई दिक्कत की बात नहीं है बट आज टाइम
अच्छी तरीके से करना मतलब गुड वे में बेड
वे में नहीं का रहा है गैस पता चलेगा आप
लोगों को स्टांप करने पहुंचाओ तो प्रिंट
करेंगे अब देखेंगे भाई ये पुराना चीज सपना
है क्या अगर मैं यहां पर यहां लिखना हूं
इसको ए लिखना हूं तो यहां पर टाइप करने के
बाद में यहां पे अगर मैं ए लिखूंगा
है जाएगा बी लिखूंगा ठीक है
तो प्लीज सब लोग मुझे छटना है बताओ की
यहां पर
लिखा हुआ आएगा यहां पर की यहां पर अपना
ये क्या लिखा है और क्या लिखा हुआ आएगा
सब लोग जल्दी बता दो हालांकि मैंने पहले
बताया था की टप्पर्स क्या होते हैं
ये वाले ब्रैकेट वाले होते हैं तो जल्दी
टाइप के अंदर टप्पल आएगा की क्या आएगा
आपको कमेंट अब आपको वैसे भी कमांड नहीं है
वैसे भी तो कमांड में मेथड कहेंगे उसको
अपन तो मेथड जो है वैसे भी आपको रिवाइज
करना है ये सारे और और भी मेथड जो है वो
आपको बताने हैं तो आप ये वाला ताई आपके
लिए टास्क है आप एक्शन के बड़े में पता
करो की क्या होता है तो एक्शन के बड़े में
पता करके और जो भी टास्क वगैरा टेलीग्राम
चैनल और लिंकडइन में बता देना अब बताएंगे
आपको ये कहां आपको बताने का है चप्पल आएगा
प्रिंस भाई टप्पल आएगा टप्पल आएगा
ठीक है
क्योंकि यह बेसिकली ये नॉर्मल पेन से इसको
इधर नॉर्मल कुछ भी ले रहा है यहां पर ठीक
है तो यह एक सफल नहीं आएगा
सिंगल भी होती है लेकिन उसको रखना का
तरीका अलग तरीके से होता है
वो इधर ही चेक किया जाता है ऐसी चीजों के
अंदर ये मतलब ये बहुत माइनर सा चीज है
लेकिन यह जो चीज होती है ना इन चीजों से
अपना थोड़ा सा पता लगता है की यार अपन ने
कितना चीजों के अंदर देखें थे अपन ठीक है
ठीक है तो यह इतना सा डिफरेंस होते हैं
छोटे-मोटे से जो अपने थोड़े बेसिक्स को
ऊपर नीचे कर देते हैं हालांकि यह भी नहीं
है की भाई अपने बेसिस खराब खराब है भाई
यार जो चीज अपन वो भी पहले पैकेज में राहत
है ये भी ऐसे ही राहत है बट हां ये चीज
चलती है ऐसे ही है
ए बी सी
दी
होता है लेकिन लिस्ट नहीं होता है
मतलब इन प्रोग्राम चेंज नहीं कर सकते अगर
आप चेंज हो जाएगा लेकिन जब अपन कर रहे
होते हैं तो उसे दौरान अगर अपन को टप्पल
में कुछ चेंज करने हो तो वह चेंज कर पन
पॉसिबल नहीं
ठीक है
वहां पर
मैं यहां पर इसको वन लिखो
प्लीज
2 ठीक है
[हंसी]
लिस्ट ऑफ जो सेट्स तीनों के अंदर
तो ठीक है
तो
चाट के अंदर
नहीं आता है
चलो मैं ही बता देता हूं
क्या करेंगे
तो समझ में ए गया रहेगा
तो अब अगर मैं चाहूं
तो इसके अंदर मैं यहां पर लिख सकता हूं
बी लिखेंगे
कन्वर्ट किया लिस्ट के अंदर यहां पर यहां
देखिए तप है यहां बाहर निकालने के बाद
लिस्ट हो गया ये अभी पूरा लिस्ट हो गया
अभी लिस्ट को अपने स्टोर किया अपने वे के
अंदर मैं फिर से एक बार समझा देता हूं
क्या हुआ है अभी की ये अपना टप्पल है इस
एप्पल ने कन्वर्ट किया लिस्ट में एमसीएफ
किया आपने बी में अब बी में से करने के
बाद लिस्ट अपनी बन गई है वे के अंदर ये तो
अभी तक नहीं है ये तो अभी भी टक्कर ही है
ठीक है
अब मैं क्या करूंगा
कोमा
आफ्टर चेंज
तो अभी क्या हुआ इसके अंदर
दाल दिया
ठीक है
तो ऐसा ही यह अपन ऐसे
चेंज कर सकते हैं कोई भी लिस्ट का चीज अपन
टप्पल में उसे कर सकते हैं उसको लिस्ट में
कन्वर्ट करके जो अपन उसे करना है मेथड जो
उसे करना है वो उसे करो फिर उसको हम वापस
से टप्पल में कन्वर्ट कर दो और वो आपका कम
वहां पे हो जाएगा ये ऐसी कुछ लॉजिकल चीज
रहती है जो अपन को खुद से सोचनी पड़ती है
जब हमने एक प्रोग्राम स्क्रिपिंग हो गया
देख करते हैं तो उसके अंदर अपन को ऐसे खुद
के लॉजिक बनाने पढ़ते हैं की यार इसको ऐसे
करेंगे थोड़ी घुमा उठाइए जुगाड़ कीजिए
इंडियन सी कर सकते हैं ठीक है आईएफ यू आर
इंडिया यू कैन डू दिस
ठीक है यह जुगाड़ वाला आइटम अपने
तो
ऐसे अपन चेंज कर सकते हैं
तो फंक्शन
तो प्रिंट इसका एक कैमरा फंक्शन है अपना
यह
डॉट अकाउंट
ठीक है
तो उसे अपना कम हो जाएगा
इंडेक्स क्या है
ये इसलिए मैंने यह सिखाई करके दिखाए ताकि
मैं ये बता सुकून की इसके अंदर
ये वन इसका मतलब ये नहीं की एक टाइम नहीं
है नेक्स्ट का मतलब ये है इसके अंदर की ये
इसके नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन क्या है
यहां पर
थोड़ा सा एकदम
तो यह ऐसा है
अब इसके अंदर वही से चीज कम करती है की
चलो
15 मिनट के अंदर मैक्सिमम हो जाना चाहिए
कंटिन्यू सर प्लीज
बताओ आगे
काफी लोग
चलो बता देते हैं सब बोल रहे हो तो चलो
ठीक है आगे कर लेते हैं
तो अगर आपको इतना मजा ए रहा है तो आई होप
की आपको दोस्त लोग कोई मजा आएगा
ठीक है
अपन जाते हो सेट्स के अंदर
अब सेट्स के अंदर
जानते हैं
ईटीवी है
अपने अंदर हो सके तो पढ़ के ए जो डोंट
वारी कल बताने वाला हूं जिसके बड़े में
क्या डिस्ट क्या है डिक्शनरी क्या है यह
इसका खुलासा कल तक हो जाएगा
लेकिन ठीक है
करते रहो समझ में ए जाएगा
यह सेट हो गया
सेट
मतलब यह वाला सेट नहीं है
[हंसी]
ठीक है
अब सेट करना
सेट के अंदर क्या है
ना इन चीजों को एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते
तो मुझे सेट के बड़े में बताना पड़ा आज ये
सेट नहीं बताना है क्योंकि इतना कम का चीज
है नहीं तो इसको अपन ऊपर से देखने वाले
हैं क्योंकि अपना आगे जाएंगे ना कहानी पे
कम आने वाला है ना मैंने इसको कम कहानी और
कम में ले तो अच्छा है
इसको रखना का मतलब इस्तेमाल नहीं कर सकते
सो यह चीज है बाकी मैं इसको लिस्ट में
कन्वर्ट करके तो इस्तेमाल कर ही सकते हैं
लेकिन कन्वर्ट करना ही है तो लिस्ट कर
लेंगे सीधा सेट का ही इस्तेमाल
करूं
की बीच में ऐसे क्यों आया है
फिर भी अगर आप लोगों को अंदर थोड़ा सा
आशंका है या फिर कुछ भी है अंदर तो उसके
लिए आप इसको पता लगा के कर सकते हो
अपडेट किया अपने अपडेट में
दाल दिया
जाता है
इसमें सबके लिए बता रहा हूं मतलब
ऐसे ही ए जाएगा
अगर अगर मां लो की है ना यार
मुश्किल
ठीक है वही से ऑपरेशन कर सकते हैं से करके
उदा सकते हैं
तो यह चीज है इसके अंदर क्लियर कमेंट का
इस्तेमाल जाएगा
तो अभी
आज के लिए तो बस इतना ही
तो मैं हां
रिवाइज करता हूं आप लोगों की टैक्स
क्या-क्या है आप लोग क्या करना है तो मैं
यहां पर
लिंक में जाऊंगा अपने लिंकडइन पर जान के
बाद में
यहां पर
सर्च भी करोगे तो भी आएगा मेरा पहले से
सर्च कर रखा है तो मैं यहां पर ए जाऊंगा
अपने एकदम बढ़िया तरीके से पोस्ट के अंदर
जाऊंगा
उसके कमेंट्स के अंदर आपको
अपना जो मैं स्टॉक देने वाला हूं जो आपके
टास्क है सबसे पहले आपको नेगेटिव
इंडेक्सिंग करके बताना है
ना उसके
ऐसे
मैंने ऐसे करके दिखा देना
आपको ठीक है
जो मुझे कल आप लोग या फिर कमेंट के अंदर
मुझे बताना की एक और क्या चीज होती है जो
मैंने आप लोग को बताई नहीं छुपा के रखें
आप लोगों से मैं चाहता हूं की वो लोग आपको
पता करके मुझे बताओ और मैं देखूं क्या आप
लोग कितना खुद से पढ़ पाते हो और कितना
साइज बताओ ना की ये ना पढ़ने से मतलब कोई
आपको आगे बताया तो उससे क्या राहत है ना
की अभी तक मैंने मैं आपको सिर्फ बता दूंगा
तो मुझे कुछ फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा मैं बता के
खत्म कर दूंगा तो बट उससे क्या रहेगा ना
आपका नॉलेज लिमिटेड र जाएगा की हां अभी
इतना ही
इतना ही है बट जब आप गूगल करोगे
फर्स्ट मैंने भी ये कलर सेकंड हैंड में भी
कहूंगा थर्ड में भी खाने वाला हूं तो
सेकंड दे के अंदर भी मैं ये का रहा हूं
आपको की अपना गूगले बेस्ट है गूगल करो ना
आप एक प्रॉब्लम गूगल करोगे 4 आपको
सॉल्यूशन पता लगेंगे अब वो जो चार्ज
सॉल्यूशन है ना आप उनको कर अलग-अलग तरीके
से इंप्लीमेंट करके देखो की हां आपका
सॉल्यूशन और कैसे कैसे तरीके से हो सकता
है
नहीं पड़ता है बस अब गूगल करते रहो चीज
अपने आप क्लियर होती रहेगी अब मतलब बस वही
है चीज है इसके अंदर
और लिस्ट के और भी मैथर्ड पता करके बताओ
लिस्ट के कोई भी लिस्ट के और भी मैसेज
मुझे बताओ यहां पर कमेंट में कमेंट में
यहां पे दाल दो फाड़ दो पूरा कमेंट और
बताओ मुझे की कौन-कौन से अपने होते हैं
अपना लिस्ट और कौन-कौन से मैथर्ड होते हैं
नेगेटिव स्लैश में मुझे करके यहां पे कोड
लिख के भेजो स्क्रीनशॉट भेजो जो करना है
वो करो कमेंट में करो टेलीग्राम पे करो बट
ये लिंकडइन वाले कमेंट में करना है
कंपलसरी है टास्क करने के बाद में और
टेलीग्राम चाहे तो कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
हो आप पूछ सकते हो सो थॉट्स जो गैस आज के
लिए और एक बार मुझे फाटक से मुझे एक बार
पूरे लेक्चर का फीडबैक दे दो की पूरा
लेक्चर आपको कैसा लगा है एक शब्द में पूरा
फीडबैक आप मुझे कमेंट्स में बता दो ताकि
ये लेक्चर में यहां पे भी और कर सुकून
बहुत मजा ए गया सर जी
मिलती है